you are what a cold season PD
hi to gogo here and welcome to the final
episode of the rise and fall of no Kia
it's been an amazing journey so far
we've traveled from 1800s to the year
2006 looking at Nokia's history and how
they rose to power thanks for joining me
thus far in today's final episode of the
series we'll be taking a look at how
Nokia fell the story of Nokia's decline
starts badly but ends up terrible as
you'll soon see the company succumbed to
a wolf in sheep's clothing let's begin
in the mid 2000s Nokia's end series with
the flagship product line the n95 was a
case in point it had all the makings of
a modern smartphone just the wrong type
of human-machine interaction the series
received a generally positive reception
until the industry was shaken in 2007
the major blows Nokia arrived to an
Apple released the iPhone it was a phone
with a full touch interface much like
the LG Prada before it but the
difference with Apple's product and the
secret to its success was the capacitive
touchscreen display and desktop routes
in its OS suddenly the n95 didn't look
so impressive anymore and the very next
year the game was about to change again
Google released their first Android
phone and the famous Battle of the
smartphone OSS had begun however Nokia
did actually respond with the old
touchscreen 5800 xpressmusic phone it
was a commercial success and was largely
praised for a supplied stylus and a low
price but it was actually viewed
negatively by critics for his poor
software implementation so great here we
have Nokia responding to Google and
Apple right so where did it all go wrong
how did Nakia fall we'll hold on to your
hats people because what you're about to
hear is the real employee inside
information that you
not get anywhere else on YouTube a
special thanks to the Wall Street
Journal for this one the first set of
inside information we get is from former
vice president and chief of designer
Nokia Frank nuovo he was at this
position during Nokia's glory days and
resigned in 2006 when the management
changed this is new over speaking I look
back and I think that Nokia was just a
very big company that started to
maintain his position more than innovate
for new opportunities he continues all
of the opportunities were in front of
Nokia and they were working on them but
the key word was a sense of urgency
there was a real sense of just saying
we'll get to that eventually
for example Nokia had a prototype 8-inch
tablet computers years before the iPad
even emerged okay so we see that Nokia
was a bit slow to move but that couldn't
really be all let's take a deeper look
into Nokia's mindset this is actually
pretty incredible Nokia's engineers
stated that the iPhone was way too
expensive to manufacture and only worked
on 2g networks primitive when compared
to nock use 3G technology they scoffed
as the iPhone didn't even come close to
passing Nokia's rigorous drop tests it
seems funny today but it's almost
understandable from Nokia's point of
view back then
despite this the iPhone ended up selling
like hotcakes and by 2008 Nokia's
executives realized that matching Apple
slick operating system amounted to their
biggest challenge and the number one
priority so internally within Nokia one
team tried to revamp Symbian the aging
operating system that most Nokia phones
ran and another effort eventually dubbed
MeeGo tried to build a new system from
the ground up people involved in both
efforts say that the two teams competed
with each other for support within the
company and attention from the top
executives it was a problem that plagued
Nokia's R&D operations as the saying
goes
anything that's divided internally will
never succeed as Alister Curtis Nokia's
chief designer from 2006 to 2009 put it
you are spending more time fighting
internal politics than doing design key
business partners were also frustrated
as well the chief executive of chip
manufacturer Qualcomm Paul Jacobs
started working with Nokia in 2008 his
main complaint was that Nokia really
took too much time when working on
strategies this is a quote from mr.
Jacobs we would present Nokia a new
technology that too
would seem a big opportunity but instead
of diving into this opportunity nokia
would spend a long time maybe six to
nine months assessing the opportunity
and by this time the opportunity just
often went away the real problem was
that Nokia's management just couldn't
steer the huge multinational company
quickly enough they seemed to just keep
throwing money at the problem instead of
innovating through it with wisdom even
jumping over to Android seemed like a
short-term solution a shortcut
Nokia smartphone division management se
van jockey dismissed the idea of Android
as peeing in your pants for warmth in
the winter
ouch in 2010 Canadian Stephen Elop took
over the helm a bit of his history first
in 2005
he worked for macro media which got
bought by Adobe during his time as CEO
and from 2008 to 2010 he worked for
Microsoft working in Microsoft Office
products at the time of Eve ops arrival
Nokia was spending five billion dollars
on her research and development that's
30 percent of the entire mobile
industry's total yet it remained far
from launching a legitimate competitor
to the iPhone
however Nokia did release the n8 and
n900 both good attempts but it was still
clear the Nokia was struggling to focus
on useful R&D
mr. elop had had enough he sifted
through data and visited labs around the
world to personally terminate projects
that weren't core priorities as it turns
out the organizational structure of
Nokia was also extremely convoluted in
2010 for instance Nokia was hashing out
some details of software that would make
it easier for outside programmers to
write applications that could work on
any Nokia smartphone at some companies
such decisions might be made around a
conference table but in Nokia's case it
was a nightmare according to some
insight attendees of the meeting this is
how it went down 100 engineers and
product managers from different offices
as far as Massachusetts and China were
all called in to a hotel venue in
Germany over three days Nokia employees
sat down and jotted notes meanwhile
representatives of mega Symbian and
other operating systems within Nokia all
struggled to make themselves heard as
one person recalls people were just
trying to keep their jobs
each group was a can
for delivering the most competitive
phone as you could see from this
situation it was pretty much cut through
dog-eat-dog not a good environment
however out of these meetings two OS has
emerged a new version of Symbian X
accessor - the old Symbian OS and MeeGo
a promising software that finally
arrived in the Nokia n9 although amigo
was a pretty good attempt and was a
great step in the right direction it was
too little too late the App Store was
severely undeveloped at a time when
Apple and Google's App Store's were
rocket shipping off unfortunately it was
all fruitless as the meager operating
system was discontinued in 2012 in
February 2011 Stephen Elop and Microsoft
CEO Steve Ballmer jointly announced a
major partnership between Nokia and
Microsoft which would see Nokia adopt
Windows Phone as its primary platform of
feature smartphones replacing both
Symbian and MeeGo Nokia unveiled the
first Windows Phone 7 devices on October
26 and 2011 they were the lumia 710 and
lumia 800 which was quickly followed by
the Lumia 900 in April 2012 one Nokia's
internal divisions were squabbling
Samsung overtook Nokia is the largest
phone manufacturer in the world in 2013
Nokia introduced the 925 which is a
slimmed down version of the 920 also
incorporating an aluminium design after
this Nokia went on to release the Lumia
1020 this phone was all about the camera
a 41 megapixel shooter with a Symbian
based 808 PureView technology the phone
did receive critical acclaim for its
camera and general design and
performance unfortunately there was
still the problem of apps you see the
windows marketplace used in Windows
Phone devices wasn't exactly that
vibrant quality app developers were slow
to get onboard the platform and this
ultimately hurt Nokia although the Lumia
series was doing better than Blackberry
Nokia still made an operating loss of
115 million euros with revenues falling
24% during the second quarter of 2013
but looking at the bigger picture it's
even worse
since 2011 Nokia sustained 4.1 billion
euros worth of operating losses by this
stage the game was pretty much over the
ship was sinking and the Windows
platform wasn't providing much of a
lifeboat Nokia as a company was under a
bit of pressure if it looks a beautiful
device okay that is making its
appearance in town for the first time as
this as a show Erik okay but as for
future products of 9:28 when if she's
coming I'll say a couple things about
future products I can do one key I have
my iPhone oh how embarrassing I I don't
want to have an iPhone I want to I want
to I won't take care of that for you
right here there you go I was to have a
Nokia 4 gone I want another Nokia phone
because I believe in you and I believe
in Nokia yes but I want to have that
Lumia 9 to 8 when do I get it so let me
tell you what we're doing in the future
tell me before that then doom I will not
it not sorry can't answer okay
on the 3rd of September 2013 Microsoft
announced that it would acquire Nokia's
mobile phone division in a deal
totaling 7 billion US dollars Stephen
Elop would also step down as Nokia CEO
and rejoin Microsoft as the head of
devices but the question is was this a
conflict of interest for Elop was there
a dark side behind this move as it turns
out this sadly may have been the case it
is reported that elop got an 18 point 8
million euro bonus after he sold Nokia
to Microsoft and stepped down the CEO
what's more is that this agreement was
only made on the same day as the
announcement was a lot shaky CEO
position in Nokia just a part of
Microsoft's plan to enter the smartphone
game all along we may never know for
sure in October 2014 the barrel had
begun Microsoft officially announced
that it would phase out the Nokia brand
in his promotion of the Lumia
smartphones it would now be known as
Microsoft Lumia and this sadly was the
end of Nokia's of
and maybe in some distant time and some
three back nostalgic way they could come
back but right now this really does look
like the end of the trailer for an
absolutely amazing company
so throughout history we're seeing the
same thing over and over again like palm
with webOS or Intel with mobile internet
devices or even Xerox with the graphical
user interface it's been repeatedly
demonstrated that being the first to a
good idea is no guarantee of commercial
success so I put it to you what do you
guys think of the demise of Nokia do you
think that mr. elop was guilty of
purposely selling Nokia for his own
personal gain or the gain of Microsoft I
think this may be a very interesting
comment section so broadening our field
of view let this be a lesson to any of
us that are thinking of ever running a
business be diligent be very aware of
your competitive surroundings and most
of all be prepared to swallow your pride
in order to usher in a positive change
and to leave a positive spin on things
this multinational company started from
just one man's paper mill and lasted for
over 100 years
so just goes to show if you do what's
right you can do a lot hey guys to get
here and I just want to thank you for
watching the whole way through my rise
and fall
Nakia video but an interesting story
when you think about if you start to
finish up what a lot of stuff went down
throughout Nokia's history so it's quite
interesting so yeah if you're new here
take a look around there's a few other
videos that are quite interesting and
also if you want to share this video
feel free I'm sure there's some other
people out there that would be quite
interested in the whole business idea
behind done why not kiya fell or you
know just any other interesting things
about technology they may be interested
in so I'm yeah that's all from me thanks
for watching don't forget to subscribe
give a thumbs up and I'll catch you
again soon for the next video have a
good one guys Cheers cold fusion
it's me thinking
you